à 17 jours du premier tour des élections
régionales la france insoumise espère
faire tomber la liste divers droite
représentée par xavier bertrand écoute
et d'ailleurs aurélien le coq est engagé
sur la liste pour le climat pour
l'emploi avec karima delli la région de
vaud de france est une région
particulièrement pauvre où le chômage
la désindustrialisation a fait
particulièrement des ravages et donc on
a besoin aujourd'hui de changement d'une
rupture dans les politiques à mener et
nous avec la france insoumise avec la
liste de karima delli
on propose à la fois la mise en place
d'un bouclier social pour protéger au
maximum les citoyennes et les citoyens
on propose d'avancer dans la transition
écologique parce que au delà des
gesticulations des manuels maquereau ou
de xavier bertrand dans les hauts de
france
il était important d'avancer vraiment
dans cette voie et puis on propose un
renouveau démocratique
refonder nos institutions pour que les
citoyens puissent réellement avoir accès
à leurs institutions locales
on a abordé ces élections régionales
dans une dynamique plutôt de
rassemblement plutôt l'argent on a
proposé à l'ensemble des partis
politiques de gauche europe ecologie les
verts au parti communiste de de mener
des discussions nationalement pour
trouver un accord national
ça n'a pas été possible en tout cas il
faut pas il faut pas lâcher il faut
continuer à aller au combat dans les
hauts de france on a un beau combat à
mener et on espère que les vins et les
27 points en sont incapables de
renverser la vapeur et prendre la région